so murder is legal in this movie and
people still dress up like creeps I mean
why is that
I don't maybe it's like cosplay or
something who knows the purge so the
purge stars Ethan Hawke and Lena Headey
there's this nice suburban couple
although even Hawks kind of like this
corporate dick type then they got their
huge house and tonight's a special night
because in the near future crime is
legal on 12 hours of one day which
really means yeah you can kill I don't
know about you guys but me I would raid
the max store and sell all that on
eBay it sounds like a smart idea that's
right crime is down unemployment is down
the economy is flourishing because
everyone gets all their rage out on this
purge and then this guy's running down
the street he looks like he's a mess
he's screaming for help and then Ethan
Hawke's kid turns off the security
system invites the guy into the house
the guy gets in the house ethan hawke
freaks out turns on the security system
and then it happens a bunch of really
weird creeps and creepy masks with the
leader looking like Draco Malfoy if he
was a muggle or a like he I returned to
kill him so just give him back to us
alive and we're not gonna break in and
kill you all and at that point you're
like okay this move you already had an
interesting premise worst thing they can
do is make it some cheap slasher flick
horror film you know what they do they
make it a cheap slasher flick horror
film which is about the laziest thing
you can do with a premise in the movie
being murder is legal on this day I
don't require every movie to have a
deeper meaning or anything like that I
can enjoy some fun simple entertainment
but when you have such an interesting
premise that you turn into a cheap
slasher flick horror film starts to
irritate me and it only irritates me
because at a point in this movie you sit
back and you go wait a minute I've seen
this premise in movies before nothing's
new about it you can have this premise
in a movie where murder isn't legal yeah
it's been done you can have a premise
where someone's trying to kill someone
then this family invites the guy in to
protect them and then these are
outside and they're like we want to be
polite about it giving back to us and we
won't kill you and then they don't give
them back and then the are
trying to get in now you have a home
invasion movie you don't need the
premise to be murders legal on this
night really the whole murder being
legal thing is this minor convenience or
inconvenience depending on how you look
at it just this thing that's in the
background but it doesn't really change
the plot at all when you really think
about it and that makes me just go what
a waste
yeah murder was illegal they wouldn't
have this fortress of a house that would
take these that long to break
into in the end you wind up with the
same thing they all
start getting in the house and they all
start acting like idiots I really mean
idiots - I understand you're supposed to
be crazy and they're releasing all the
rage like oh and leash the Beast so
they're gonna act kind of animalistic
but at a moment when these
realize that this family has guns and
they're shooting back it'd be like yeah
we're crazy whoa okay yeah all right all
right so apparently the family has guns
so yeah just got real we're
fighting for our lives - time to get
logical and stop dancing around the
hallways like idiots fight-or-flight
kicks in and it's amazing that even
want to live through an
experience there was a really good hit
in the movie though I'll say that Lena
Headey breaks this person's face where
you're like ouch and that was cool I'll
remember that I'll probably forget a lot
of this movie but that face break was
business the movie was well acted people
did a good job in the movie I thought
the main guy was a little creepy for the
sake of being creepy he wasn't Ben
Foster in hostage or anything like that
where you're like he was creepy Malfoy
with a mullet and you get it he has to
be creepy but in the end the movies
wasted potential and it's just a cheap
slasher flick horror movie if you want
to see a cheap slasher flick horror
movie cool but if you wanted a movie
that would explore even some of the
potential of crime and murder being
legal for one day not it in the end the
purge is probably a good time if you're
drunk yeah and now it's a party wait I
thought murder was already legal in the
90s right so your favorite home invasion
movie you have a lot to choose from so
what would it be whatever it is comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
you